au
non
bonjour
où
miku
il
à
vous
je vais pas oui ne crever coniquet des
novices ou partielle de mon appareil à
vous maintenant muet méthode
cette fumée c'est bof on me donne d'un
crâne et bouge pas donner ça c'est un
premier jour
le deuxième jour j'ai décidé de
commencer par le commencement
j'ai senti la valise et comme j'étais
noir de combrit le sable samedi c'est
benjamin toi laval en toile est utile
d'amender jeudi quand j'ai zappé vrai
nom teyssou où tu parles pas très bien
foncé en échange je t'achète rocard
tournevis touriste
merde je dois tout faire moi même
le 3ème joie
j'étais bien emmerdé le camion poubelle
du passé pour ramasser mais loser a dû
passer sur le voir c'est quoi loser ce
keylogger perdu vous avez perdu votre
chien non la course
c'est dommage oui très dommage on peut
faire une course si vous voulez et un
chômage eux ferait semblant d'être est
fiché pour vous laisser calais la course
comme ça vous arriverez premier oui tu
me comprends n'est ma course est
beaucoup plus important c'est une pause
milieu plus jeunes jour pas dans la vie
civilisée
on va tout va je gare après le désert
chez moi et on a gagné
si on a une poignée et vous gagnez quoi
la course la course et argent beaucoup
d'argent
la notoriété le succès et puis on se
sent fort
tu vois voulu on est arrivés avant les
autres on ne veut plus des gens très
rapide
ledoux et il ne véhicule cerveau dont
j'ai moins aimé des projets pour
parcourir légumes il ne s'arrête devant
bien raison et les fleurs il s'arrête
devant les fleurs les choix non je ne
sais pas je noie va toujours très sûrs
nous est déjà arrivé de retirer à m
ce n'est pas grand chose non on a des
milliers jauron produisent sur terre on
veut bien à faire gagner un boisement
merde va sano rien et puis avec les
trompes de plus air mon frère on ne
devait pas être références y en a des
qui m'a avoué qu'il a apporté quelque
chose dans le noir de la nuit comme
personne il ne pouvait pas en être un
parce que c'était presse quand même ça
ne compte pas
aujourd'hui le 4e john gaunt tenir ma
vie gilad et chercher son chat que c'est
un seul chat d'une désert enfin le seul
que je connais on se donne rendez vous
au crépuscule pour voir la naissance des
étoiles mais cela fait plus de deux
jours que je n'ai pas vu ça m'inquiète
très fort je ne dors plus la nuit
j'attends ton chat c'est un mâle ou
femelle ton chat c'est un mâle ou
femelle
je comprends pas je ne comprends pas le
sens des mots monsieur vous dit toujours
et ceci et cela
comme si on pouvait tout changer des
jours où tu fais semblant on ne sait
qu'il joue un minime neigeux injectés de
sang qui n'avait pas dormi
la pensée du panier ça s est accrue
alors le sixième jour je sais chercha
jeu petit émir et je trouvais un cadavre
et je prends plein écran et en entendant
hurler de tout ton talent sous les roues
de mou kaka c'était mon jour
je pris à moi aussi nous d'un plot de
béton
j'ai cassé mon des jeux réduits en
poussière du néant gens en savent
pour le faire disparaître hu a tout à
fait le thème jo j'étais celle ne le
désert avec qu'on peut tenir
et je crois que j'en ai moins de monde
je lui demandais
pourquoi tu as maintenant meeting ne me
répondit pas un jeune homme en est on
est à famille ta mère ton père as tu des
frères et des soeurs et un des tout ça
chez moi je suis dans le désert n'ont de
choix sous les halles on voulait voir
rien souvent par deux pas laisse moi
maintenant je rentre en jeu
je veux suivi de loin par curiosité pour
moi
il arriva devant une grande porte
hors gain de 5
je me mis à l'écart il enleva son
manteau de son il portait une robe
il en va sig en son essence sa capuche
dessous il avait de l'enjeu noir
alors je jouis que c'était un être
exceptionnel
j'attendis longtemps avant de revoir
je demande à tous au viage d'argent
personne n'ira gras il n'y a personne ce
sont nous la chine nous il n'y a pas non
plus enfin vous perdez votre auto plus
grands fous ils sont tous partis dans
les villes pour travailler mais ne femme
janvier dont nous attendons leur visite
une fois par an mais ils ne viennent
plus il ne vient plus des plus les
tempêtes de ça
au bout de quelques jours que je ne loge
et dans ce gage petit émir sont trois
mois comme un fantôme sortir on ne naît
pas
ont été tués lundi oui la halle jean
marie qui n'y avait plus d'enfants dans
ce village
mais toi j'ai un enfant l'enfant
ils nous cachent ils ne veulent pas
qu'on nous envoie à la guerre des hommes
des fois vient nous chercher
comme dans un supermarché à vers le
caddie ils veulent de la chair à canon
des bombes humaines du jus de grenade
l'année passée ils ont pris mon frère
avant ça mon cousin et le chien de ma
mère moi je m'habille en fils pour
échapper au sort défi et je m'habille
amphis pour échapper au sort des fils tu
fus ont fui ce rien et tout ça chez moi
il ment pas il ne parlait pas mais je me
sens plein du terme
je ne suis pas d'ici mon père m'a touché
dans les poubelles du rang des deux
varie de paris bah je pense des étoiles
enfin du l'étoile me souviens plus
laquelle sa vraie neige en leur temps
oh
je ne suis pas d'ici mon père m'a trouvé
dans les poubelles ou l'envié de bari de
paris marie de paris de paris d'hommes
tombés du ciel je pense que je viens d
étoiles enfin une étoile mais je
souviens plus laquelle ça fait tellement
longtemps
oh
mais grâce aux notes ou à la za regarde
j'ai toutes les brochures ici il faut
que tu m'aides je n'ai pas de famille
ton âge je n'ai pas d'âge
non il faut ton âge besoin et bien cela
dépend des jours d'efforts de quoi je me
sens plus vieille que mon père d'une
fois tout jeune un tout petit enfant
mais en comparaison avec toi j'ai
environ 10 ans gignac je ne sais pas si
on a trouvé dans une poubelle sexe
masculin féminin non libyenne je veux
mettre les deux non ce n'est pas sérieux
la nasa jeu n'entrera pas à 100 non sans
date de naissance sans âge son sexe
c'est une autre ou plus très sérieuse
s'il faut mourir
non imagine mois tels que tu veux le
plus important est que je sache d'où je
viens et qui je suis alors du cabanon
pourquoi d'autres produits sommes très
bien continuer hors saison plus grands
fous qu'elle aurait un ami sexe filles
jora biz elle chante très bien je me
sens déjà plus proche de chez moi il me
semble que j'ai des ailes comme un
oiseau
tu sais le désert c'est un grand
carrefour dans le désert on ne pense le
passé entre eux mais regarde toi tu es
là
alors que je pensais ne pas y rester
eh bien tu es là c'était au nombre un
jour j'ai croisé nos caravanes des gens
du businessman des formes de riches ils
viennent ici pour se ressourcer pour
oublier qu'il y à tous je leur parle
surtout une femme
elle se nomme betsy cette chaîne
américaine c'est elle qui me parle de la
nasa
son coach un voyage elle le fera sur la
lune elle trouve qu'ici c'est trop
polluée et se câliner désert yes miss
betty et mirta communiqué smith betty
elle est belle une belle robe s'est mis
une progression qu'il assainisse betty
l'eau je vais la chercher dans le plu
à
voice au camp sorry miss betty a alors
misé messi mais qu'est ce qu'elle est
compliquée si je n'arrose pas elle se
dessèchent situe la hausse trop elle
fuit elle est très vieille elle porte
des bagues en or à cette itw à elle
celle ci dans le soleil elle brille la
nuit je lève de toute mon âme émir jeu
seul l'achat ou pour une aqmi wallis
betty
émir c'est pas mon avenir de sony sur
rhodes
ouais mais ce petit objet
bassam thème gaza sap et le cme laisse
là souvent avec cette question comme
gravée dans mon coeur brûlante le sens
de la vie c'est quoi comment peut-on
répondre à cette question et toi
monsieur c'est quoi le sens de la vie
pour toi ô bon vers un monde de sons
monsieur c'est pourquoi convient tu sais
toi toi tu traverse le désert pour
gagner la course
c'est ça le sens de sa vie elle elle
vient ici pour oublier qu'il y à tout
faire une cure poser son corps au soleil
moi et moi seule sais quoi le sens de la
vie pour moi je ne sais pas je suis
perdu d'autres sont venus également dans
le désert avec des grands instruments
perforateur ils sont venus mettre au
fond un liquide noir ils sont venus le
chercher et tous mes amis et les pères
de mes amis sont allés au costume
cravate et me disais c'est notre mandat
au tel qu'on le vécu c'est au centre de
la terre là où il fait bon vivre quand
il fait chaud on a le climatiseur quand
il fait froid on a le chauffage on a des
voitures faut chaque habitant de nos
villes qu'on alimente du mans avec ce
liquide noir
ils sont venus mettre une grande
l'antenne dans le sol c'est le wifi ils
disent mais ça mange pas leur truc
tut tut tut tut lots alors ailleurs la
nasa personne ne répond
moi je suis pas comme ces gens je suis
un extraterrestre j'ai réfléchi deux
nuits entières et toi t'es quoi monsieur
je commençais à avoir des hallucinations
je me souvenais de ces mots mes mots
quand même seulement de 9 ans marthe et
da rocha primalan survivre beaucoup
moins 616 dépasser site
ils me regardaient bizarrement ce tu me
laisses dans un profond silence
le lendemain matin n'était plus là je
rhume le sensation de saman l'essentiel
est invisible pour les yeux
pardon jeudi l'essentiel est invisible
pour les yeux tu sais où tu fais
semblant ces jeux et thon rouge n'avait
pas dormi mais il n'avait pas d'en
griller une dans ces jeux c'est monsieur
cette nuit j'ai regardé les étoiles
comme je fais toutes les nuits et
brouillard c'est bien tu vois le milieu
dans le noir et la voix non plus mais
c'est la grande allée voulait voir et
quand le soleil est venu avec la lumière
j'ai senti la ville en morts il a tout
balayé cela faisait deux semaines que
j'étais dans le désert et camions
pouvaient y passer je me demandais même
s'ils se sont même pas rendu compte que
j'avais disparaît je dois bien te bats
c'est réunir oui je sais ni un quart des
passes sur les trois jours n'oublie pas
travaux mais ce la lettre pas cela être
pour la nasa
une vague j smith mais qui paiera le
stage elle me l'a promis voici son
adresse continue jusqu'à sortir
définitivement d'ici miss betis watson
descendant d'africain stars d'hollywood
aux yeux ça j'adore par l un des charmes
enseignants commises nous sommes le seul
marc grosjean ce jeudi vers ça en
sanglots récemment je l'attends dit
tiens mouche toi à moi elle ne me sers
plus ma dernière auprès d'une amie
feront ainsi à condamner des étoiles
corps ne seront là haut nous pourrons
nous faire d'ici
quand je relis herald et puis dans le
sable chaud étaient tous égards à nyon
tout son espace pour aminé sorti de ma
poche ou et peut observer par la milice
lissant du vent geste est mouillé et des
parents des joueurs laisse le temps de
chercher mon ami problème gilles de
moteur jacques servier pas jusqu'à
maison paternelle revenir à mirador de
qui parlez-vous
je sais que vous cachez vos enfants les
suisses et et l'être exceptionnel fille
et fils tu trouvé deux jumelles à paris
or noir de vote existants à ma fille
mira est morte
nous avons retrouvé son corps tout près
du grand puits aux vip et a connu la
plus mortelle des vip et a connu dans
les grands sables
le gars est soignée l'état ne me dit pas
assez
ne tardez pas il ne sert à rien de
rester le soleil du jeu les toiles aux
travaux visage s'affaisser doucement les
julia le car jaune est à nouveau comme
un bateau prêt à embarquer league en se
vidant de son sang
mais jean me lâcher
la meute en dix mois la compagnie
jusqu'au navire où étaient quand de mon
ami je voulais le voir il est sur la
terre de nos ancêtres
il ya deux ans aujourd'hui c'est
l'anniversaire de sa mort et aujourd'hui
il a enjoint de louge étoiles
on est porte du car
je vous ai marre je sais pas on est
aussi une amie ignora morte de deux ans
comment est ce possible
le car démarre et l'amazigh @ rapproche
de ma chemise à l'intérieur vous partiez
nombre une forme de la main ces radars
de ma chemise à un terrain mou pas prier
non lof miss betting fille de la célèbre
star mariah à hollywood
régis à l'ére être posés comme des mains
j'ai varié à internet nous formuler de
la nasa
non adam oui non ils ravagent 16 ans
sexe n'oublie pas ta promesse monsieur
la route de monde a pris vie aux années
d'oubli et m'en fous de bailly trouver
dans le baiser à aubigny je ne voulais
pas m'en débarrasser j'oubliais dans un
cri mois et le jour où un petit garçon
finisher fut un gros caillou et sous un
régime pour arrêter les plans de pouvait
arracher la manche de ma chemise
israël un couteau une cravate qui saigne
à une cuisse on va grandir et aériens
ce jour là je n'ai cherché non là
je reviens au fin fond du tiroir de mon
bureau
j'y connais atteindre et l'envoyer aux
usa depuis ce jour tous les soirs je
regarde les étoiles sanu mais une à une
je les salue du doubs au fond de mon âme
et conscience et je me terme d'un et la
housse plusieurs qui se déploie entre
les points essentiels est ainsi prêt
pour les yeux
devait se joue tous les matins la douce
lumière du soleil à craindre est un epic
aux demandes de chaleur parcours tout en
rondeurs qui craint de minuit branche à
sensation d'être en vie
et
mais
qui
non
enfin
m
là
oh